Excited
I havent been this excited
In my whole life
We got Outlast 2
Right in front of us
Part of me is like
Fuck this.
(laughs)
Another part of me is like
FUCK!
YES!
(cringy laugh)
The DLC of Outlast was one of the best
Horror... games... experiences
That we got in a very, very long time.
You scared?
(Sensual beard lick)
Dont worry!
Papa Pewdz is here.
LETS GO!
So this is the demo
We got to play the Demo in Outlast 1
(Papa Pewdz noticed all of yall)
Thank you red barrels (?)
Welcome to the Outlast two demo
You're Blake Langermon
LANGERMANN!
A cameraman working with your wife, Lynn
The two of you are investigative journalists willing to take risks
and dig deeper to uncover the stories no one else will dare touch.
You're following a trail of clues that started with a seemingly impossible murder of a pregnant woman known as...
...Jane Doe
JANE DOH!
Everyone knows pregnant ladys cant die!
They got that shield from the bab...
I'm sorry.
The investigation has lead you miles into the Arizona desert
To a darkness so deep that no one could shed light upon it
In a corruption so profound that going mad may be the only sane thing to do!
ooh I like that sense
Allright
Without further ado, lets begin!
Make sure you're watching in headphones!
... In headphones?
Fullscreen!
Oh god...
Why did you lose the engine?!
(Cringes awkwardly)
Jesus...
Holy fucking... Shit.
That felt like real terror.
Fucking hell, gave me ss-shivers.
Oh god, what is this?
LYNN LANGERMAN?!
Oh!
What the- Oh shit!
Dude!
Where the hell?
Am I?
Yep, oh there's my glasses.
What am I Wilma?
(Impression) My glasses, my glasses!
(Impression) I can't see without my glasses!
Ok... Woah
This looks fucking amazing.
Oh I fell down this...  this cliff
Are we getting up?  Oh we are.
Come on... Lahgerman.
You can do it.
And so, our Outlast, journey begins.
(Reads text)To raise your camcorder press right mouse button
Oh my god...
Lynn are you here?
Oooooh here we are!
Back at it again!
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I am not- Barrels!
Wheels!
I hate this al-
Should we knock?
Ya?
Oh ok! He- Hello?
It's Poodiepie.
What a piece of shit house, hello, is anyone in there?
The fuck is this?
Shift to run.
Not sure if I should run downhill, that seems like a bad-
What was that?!
What the fuck is out there?!
Oh god this is fucking creepy man.
OH!
Ok, ok, ah cactus.
(Shouts) Oh! Jesus Christ, scared the shit out of me cactus.
Fuck you cactus.
That fucking hurt.
You hit me right in the crotch.
Oh god it's getting dark man.
It's getting well dark man.
What's in here?
A bucket.
Yes of course, I have the same bucket.
Bought it off Tesco.
HELLO?!
OH! (Swedish Swearing)
Oh!
Heeey.
Alright that's cool, I'm just gonna go-
(Breaths in) BATTERIES!
How are you doing there buddy?
Dude you look good, honestly like.
Oh that's another traveler isn't it?
Ok.
Well don't mind if I take your batteries, you son of a bitch.
FUCK OFF!
I GOT MY BATTERIES!
I don't need you, I don't need anyone.  Alright?  I'm out.
(Hand motions) Poods out.
Aw shit I ran out of batteries.  Ok we got to reload.
Hello Jesus.
WOAH!  What the fuck?!
You fucking asshole!
Oh what the fuck are you doing?!
LYNN?!
Fuck me.
Why is there a tricycle here?
That's like... Bad news in horror 101.
Oh my god!  What the fuck?!
Is that a cow?
If only Leo was here, he'd go right in.
Give me another Oscar.
I'm ready.
I'm ready (Laughs)
*Ugh!
Smells so bad (Chuckles)
Fucking creepy-ass villagers.
OH! Fuck, ok, alright.  Everyone take a-
Ok so if I hit ALT, I turn around super fast.
Oh ya, cause when you run you can look behind, oh my god, fuck that.
Hello there mister man?
Man you look good man.
Let's go inside
S' cuza, s' cuza da me?
It's Poodiepie for the Pizzaria.
Did someone just yell what?
Man...
Alright but this is pretty good so far.
Getting some good, uh...
...Coverage for my journalist.
What a nice town!
Open window...
OOOH MY GOD!
Fuck!
Fuck indeed!
Jesus Christ!
Alright we're in.
Jesus...
What a nice, cozy place.
Hey they got corn and everything!
That's lovely.
Anyone in here?
Think we're ok (?)
How's it going in here guys?
Maybe there's some...
...BATTERIES!
In this.
No.  Oh you see the... audio on the cameras.
The fuck?
Alright, I suppose we got out.
Oooh, that's cool man.
This is so fucking cool.
Alright, well, so far we haven't died.
So I guess we go in here.  Hello everyone.
(Gibberish)
Here.
Alright.
Aw fuck.
You know shit's about to go down...
...When the drum starts hitting you.
What a lovely place.  What a...
..."Nice," religious town.
HEEEY.
NOOO.
I hear you Ethan Bradberry.
You son of a...
...Bradberry.
The fuck are you doing out there in the woods?!
I ain't scared!
(Attempts to read)Satanas eenimeecaldai
I think they spelled bananas wrong.
Am I right crow?
I'm right, I'm always right.
Ya, no, uh, sure, why not go down here?
This is a great place.
(Stutters) Really enjoying this.
Ok.
Let's see what wonderful things happen down here (?)
AY, it's a teddy!
AY, how you-
Oh, you're missing an eye teddy.  What the fuck man?
Let's find your eye teddy.
This is probably some...
"Nest"
of...
...Demons (?)
That's, fine.
No big deal.
Ok- OH!
What a lovely chandelier.
It's so pretty I wonder where they got it.
(Cringes) OOOOOH!!
DUDE!!!
UGH!!
THAT'S NOT A CARPET!!
THAT'S BABIES!!
UGH!!
(WTF Pewds?)
THE FUCK MAN?!
That's not cool man!
Oh! Lookada! the sound!
Why do I keep walking on them?!  I don't know!  Buuut the fuck!
Forgot how fucked up Outlast is!
Jesus Christ!
(Extended) Ugh!
Alright...
This is, fantastic man.
Hey horse, how you doing there buddy?
Why is the horse whispering to me?
Fuck you horse, I'm gonna ride you now.
The fuck is going on here?
Fuck you swing.
The hell is this?  Hello?
OOOOOO!
OH!
Did I just lose my tongue virginity?
Alright Bros.
I'm gonna have to end that episode there.
But I'll be back soon with another episode!
Leave a like in the meanwhile.
Let me know if you want me to play the full game of this.
I think it would be so cool.
I don't know man.
Should I do it? (Cringy laugh)
Thank you so much for watching!
(Kiss)
And as always... Stay awesome Bros.